crise sanitaire qui dure maintenant
depuis près de deux ans ce qui n'arrange
pas le moral des français beaucoup se
sentent fatigués voire épuisé une fin
d'année 2021 difficile avec la vague
omicron même si beaucoup espèrent une
amélioration pour 2022 on a parlé avec
notre éditorialiste michel fize michel
fize bonjour joua bonnes années bonheur
oui voilà même si ceux qui nous
regardent à une banale et 2022 même si
les premiers mois s'annoncent difficiles
là on vient de le dire le locaux vides
domine encore notre quotidien le
quotidien de tous les français c'est
l'une de leurs principales inquiétudes
aujourd'hui alors vous allez vous l'avez
rappelé bon les français ils sont
fatigués un fatigue de soi fatigue des
autres aussi quelquefois on l'a vu avec
la montée des violences conjugales
par exemple bon ils sont déprimés ils
sont ils sont en colère même quelquefois
dans l'incertitude du lendemain alors je
crois qu'aujourd'hui ils ont de grosses
inquiétudes dont celle dont on parle
beaucoup évidemment lakovic 19 mai
l'inquiétude pour leur pouvoir d'achat
pour leur pouvoir de vivre décemment
tout simplement on
on peut rappeler l'envolée des prix de
l'énergie à ces derniers mois l'envolée
des prix des produits alimentaires des
assurances des taxes des impôts toute
sorte un les factures s'alourdisse au
fil des semaines et au fil des mois ça
c'est le concret 1 c'est effectivement
quelque chose d'ailleurs qui a échappé
semble-t-il aux prises en date qui n'a
pas du tout abordé cette question du
pouvoir économique des français et des
plus démunis en particulier faut savoir
que quand on gagne 500 euros par mois ce
qui est le cas pour une personne au rsa
une personne d'une personne sol il reste
pas beaucoup quand on a fait le tour
évidemment des des rayons des rayons
alimentaires voilà donc beaucoup de
français n'arrivent plus à joindre les
deux bouts et pour beaucoup les fun mois
commence le 10 voire avant avec parfois
un endettement avant même que
le traitement ne soit 2 soit ne soit
arrivé voilà alors la deuxième grosse
inquiétude c'est effectivement la copie
de lakovic 19 parce que bon c'est
quelque chose qui est toujours la montée
de la vague au micron
aujourd'hui une quatrième dose dont on
commence dont on commence à parler voilà
donc ça tourne un peu au cauchemar on a
l'impression parfois d'être dans un
mauvais film l'américain de série b
voilà quand est-ce que ça va se terminer
avec un scénario qui semble se répéter
indéfiniment et là c'est évidemment les
lacets évidemment les les gens alors les
français aussi s'interroge par exemple
sur les chiffres à quoi sert-il de nous
communiquer le nombre de cas sachant que
le nombre de cas n'équivaut pas au
nombre de malades donc ya effectivement
une irritation de l'affolement qui
s'empare des états mais aussi avec sept
chiffres qu'on a lens tous les soirs
aussi voilà et puis bon et puis il ya
aussi ce que j'appellerais mois
volontiers l'abrutissement médiatique 1
quand effectivement on répète à longueur
de temps
les mêmes choses qu'on revient sur les
mêmes mesures qu'on assiste à ce ballet
interminable de médecins qui pour
beaucoup d'ailleurs n'exprime mène pas
de position scientifique mais simplement
une opinion l'opinion l'opinion du
moment voilà il ya un sentiment de
ras-le-bol de trop plein voilà par
rapport à un vide encore une fois de vie
pour beaucoup et français aussi qui se
sentent perdus avec les annonces du
gouvernement
n'ont ils pas quelquefois le sentiment
d'être à la naissance de marionnette
entre les mains d'un pouvoir qui
finalement navigue à vue
on cherche depuis deux ans la stratégie
sanitaire 1 dans cette affaire dudu
coronavirus on voit simplement des
mesures qui se succèdent qui s'empilent
plus ou moins cohérentes d'ailleurs
plutôt incohérente voilà et tout ceci ne
ne dessinent pas une perspective
optimiste parce que bon l'optimisme doit
doit reposer quand même sur sur sur du
concret et puis bien sûr on voit des
mesures qui avantage les 1 et pénalise
les autres on l'a beaucoup dit à propos
des discothèques par exemple de tout ce
qui est de l'ordre de l'événementiel des
des spectacles en général voilà donc les
français finissent par se dire mais à
quoi bon ces discriminations
donc à quoi bon traiter différemment les
uns les uns et les autres sur quel
fondement il ya des aberrations
évidemment que les français supportent
supporte de moins en moins comment
redonner l'espoir aux français
puisque là quand on vous entend parler
voilà c'est vrai qu'on ne peut pas être
optimiste pour l'année d'abord je pense
que nous rêvons tous ça part un peu
paradoxal du monde d'avant c'est à dire
le monde sans épidémie mais nous rêvons
aussi d'un nouveau monde celui dont on
parle pas un monde qui serait débarrassé
du chômage de la précarité de la
pauvreté qui a quand même explosé au
cours de ces dernières dernières années
je pense aussi qu'il faut remettre il
faut remettre la démocratie sur des bons
rails la france n'est pas une propriété
privée elle n'appartient à personne elle
est à l' usage de tous donc je pense
qu'il faut développer de bons rails
faire confiance aux français leur
laisser des responsabilités par exemple
pour les entreprises leur laisser
l'autonomie 1 les acteurs économiques
sont tout à fait à même de savoir
quelles sont les bonnes mesures à
appliquer dans telle ou telle
circonstance dans tel ou tel tel secteur
se sont pas des enfants les acteurs
économiques donc c'est important et puis
aussi poursuivre avec ce grand mot la
décentralisation il faut poursuivre la
décentralisation politique
1les ces collectivités territoriales
encore une fois le pouvoir de gérer
leurs propres affaires et d'abord les
affaires les affaires sanitaires je
pense que ça c'est extrêmement important
et puis il faut il faut je crois ne pas
se substituer aux chefs d'entreprise 1
les chefs d'entreprise ils sont tout à
fait l'habitude il gère d'ailleurs
depuis le q2 et je pense que les
français ont appris j'aime pas beaucoup
l'expression à vivre avec parce qu'il
faut pas s'habituer à vivre avec
avec un virus un l'objectif c'est quand
même de de nous en débarrasser mais je
pense encore une fois qu'avec
l'expérience acquise au cours de ces
presque deux années maintenant
chacun à son niveau est capable de
savoir dans quelles circonstances il
faut porter un masque ne pas ou ne pas
le porter le masque en extérieur par
exemple à quoi cela sert-il quand on est
dans un petit parc tout seul voilà je
pense que chacun doit pouvoir choisir
ses contraintes si ça la démocratie
c'est quand on choisit ses contraintes
dernière question c'est que le
gouvernement a une grosse responsabilité
sur les épaules vous parliez tout à
l'heure justement de ces chiffres que
l'on voyait que l'on attendait tous les
soirs est ce que la communication doit
être changé aussi pour apporter un peu
plus de sérénité dans les foyers je
pense que
il faut apporter de la sérénité en
reconnaissant les difficultés 1 revient
encore une fois au discours du président
de la république qu'il a beaucoup parlé
de la france et très peu des français
est finalement or nous sommes confrontés
à une double crise à une crise sanitaire
et puis une crise économique et sociale
qui perdure malgré tout les appuis qui
ont pu être accordés alors d'ailleurs
d'une manière aussi un peu discriminante
aux uns et aux pas aux autres quand on
regarde un peu les les entreprises voilà
mais je pense que nous avons tous
l'espoir que le 1er janvier prochain ici
même nous parlons d'autre chose que de
la copie 19 merci beaucoup en tout cas
michel fils de nous avoir éclairé